le patron de lyon électrique demande à
québec et à ottawa de prioriser l'achat
local marc bédard souhaite que les deux
paliers de gouvernements changent leurs
critères d'appels d'offres en matière de
transport pour favoriser les entreprises
d'ici et qu'il mette fin à la règle du
plus bas soumissionnaire
le pdg de lyon marc bédard est avec nous
bonsoir monsieur bédard bon en ce moment
mais ce que fait lyon vous demandez donc
la création d'une clause d'achat local
une sorte de buy canada act pourquoi il
ya plusieurs raisons à son affaire il ya
tellement de compagnie aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont entrain de s'investir pour
créer un écosystème au québec et au
canada donc faut donner un tremplin à
l'écosystème c'est bien évidement puis
l'autre chose qui est très importante
également c'est que pour lui je vous
dirais les cinq six prochaines années
l'écosystème vont être nourrie par des
subventions gouvernementales et des
subventions qui vont aller dans
l'électrification pour des cinq six
prochaines années donc l'argent des
contribuables doit absolument retourner
aux contribuables ce serait une deuxième
raison l'autre raison c'est que y'a un
buy american act qui existe aux états
unis comme vous le savez bien et il ya
également des clauses de protectionniste
dans plein de pays surtout en asie et en
amérique du sud et en europe également
donc tenter d'en locaux canadiens soient
pas les victimes je comprends pas
pourquoi un critère de plus qui
viendrait vous favorisez alors que vous
le dites vous même vous avez déjà
beaucoup de subventions de la part des
gouvernements non mais parce que ces
subventions nouveau à l'aide des
compagnies qui est qui et qui produisent
des produits américains alors je pense
pas que les payeurs de taxes veulent
envoyer leur argent pour pas créé
d'emplois ici au québec on sait que
quand on crée un emploi au québec un
emploi manufacturier et environs de
certains disent emplois indirects qui
vont être créés donc c'est important que
ça retourne au niveau manufacturier
lalonde on parle toujours des liens on
parle de tout le secteur manufacturier
puis vous savez quand nous on veut
vendre aux états unis là bas il faut
absolument se plier aux règles du flyer
le feu nova bus le fait lyon le fait les
autres ont payé deux fois également est
ce que ce serait légale de faire ça de
dire qu'on favorise clairement nos
entreprises au canada ben moi je
comprends qu absolument ça serait ça
serait légale et les autres pays le font
à peu près tous on a des accords de
libre-échange comprend qu'elle buy
american act mais c'est dans un pays qui
s'appelle les états unis nous est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas des problèmes s'ils
ont décidé de faire une chose pareille
je crois que non je pense qu'il ya des
façons de faire intelligemment dans le
respect des règles internationales dans
les aspects des compagnies les pays le
font en ce moment on se boit un peu avec
une main dans le dos quand on le fait
pas quand on ne va pas nous mêmes donc
non il ya des façons de le faire lorsque
mais quand vous êtes aux états unis par
exemple vous êtes soumis aux buy
american act c'est pour ça que vous
faites des contrats mais un seul
américain n'est ce pas exactement et
est-ce que vous avez donc pourcentage
minimum de contenu local est ce que
c'est 100% ce pourcentage là où il est
plus bas n'auriez plus bas que 100% donc
il ya des lieux des règles est ajusté
aux alentours de 70% ok récemment mais
également il ya des clauses d'assemblage
final par exemple ans donc c'est pô
juste le contenu il à l'assemblage
également donc l'endroit où il est
assemblé donc faut se conformer à toutes
à toutes ces règles l'offre est ce que
vous pensez qu'on devrait avoir les
mêmes pourcentages et si vous parlez de
70 % de contenu local
il faut encore le chauffage faut le
faire intelligemment nous faut le faire
avec beaucoup de doigté dans
l'électrique aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
batterie
on n'a pas de cellule batteries qui sont
faits dans le nord au niveau du jiangxi
c'est ça ça vient de la chine ou de la
corée un petit peu des états unis donc
c'est certain qu'à ce niveau là on
pourrait pas compétitionné demain matin
de notre côté nous on prend vraiment que
on devrait avoir le le contrôle de nos
ressources à partir de la ressource
naturelle jusqu'au produit final qui va
jusqu'au recyclage du produit tous sont
en fait ça fait partie des costauds mais
il ya quand même de vos compétiteurs qui
dénonce un certain favoritisme du
gouvernement à votre endroit dans le
dossier des autobus scolaires est ce
qu'une clause d'achat local dans les
appels d'offres gouvernementaux vous
viendra pas vous avantager encore
davantage non absolument apprendre en
fait il ya pas de favoritisme note dan
la seule chose que le gouvernement du
québec l'a fait c'est font très très
bien les choses c'est qu'ils ne manque
que le produit soit fabriqué au canada
rien de plus naturel exactement ce qu'on
demande dans le reste du canada puis
quand je dis financement fédéral
également donc aucun favoritisme nahd
dans tout le monde peut avoir droit aux
subventions gouvernementales
les transports scolaires mais il s'agit
de produire le véhicule au canada c'est
la seule condition est ce que la règle
pisseurs vous demandez c'est également
du plus bas soumissionnaire
avantage les entreprises qui fabriquent
à l'étranger est-ce que sk en retour ça
vient faire en sorte que ont fait
fabriquer davantage à l'étranger et
c'est pour ça que vous contestez la
règle du plus bas soumissionnaire tout à
fait il ya comme deux églises à celle du
fabricant canadien convient désir puis à
7 du plus bas soumissionnaire a fait le
plus bas soumissionnaire cette fameuse
règle ans c'est un tube innovation quand
on veut vendre le plus beau possible on
n'investit pas on arrête de faire
évaluer évoluer la qualité du produit
également alors nous ce qu'on dit la
règle du plus bas soumissionnaire dans
certaines industries ou dans le passé
salut du bon mais aujourd'hui dans le
type d'économie qu on est surtout au
niveau des véhicules électriques
évidemment c'est une règle ans qu'on
peut pas en durée et en plus c'est une
vraie qui va favoriser l'achat dans
d'autres pays où souvent les règles
sociales et environnementales sont
complètement différente également est-ce
que vos demandes aujourd'hui pourrait
faire grimper finalement le prix de vos
produits à la vente
absolument pas nous il ya un prix il ya
un prix qui nous permet d'arriver
aujourd'hui puis avec le volume nous ce
qu'on voit c'est que au contraire le
prix votre décembre donc plus à vendre
ni du volume dans l'écosystème plus le
prix va descendre donc c'est toute
l'économie canadienne qui va gagner
c'est toujours passionnant de vous
parler c'est intéressant votre
proposition va voir ce que ce que savoir
faire pour la suite marc bédard merci
beaucoup merci bonsoir bonsoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh